[Music]
my name is Monica Trotsky I'm a product
manager here at Google I focused on
encryption at rest encryption key
management and as we'll be talking about
today so I'm a crypto nerd but you might
all be at fault
I'll cover some primitives as well
before jumping in we'll talk about how
we encrypt data at rest at Google the
options that you have as a developer and
some partners that you can work with in
order to have more options
I also apologize I'm kind of losing my
voice so you can decide at the end if
this was more painful for you or for me
so first let's talk about what kinds of
encryption we we have in in general so
you can think about encryption in three
different states encryption at rest
encryption in transit or encryption in
use encryption at rest is what you use
to protect your data from exfiltration
in case your device is stolen etc it's
how its protected at the base layer on
on Hardware on a device this is the
focus of the talk that we'll have today
the second point encryption in transit
is how we protect data when it's moving
between to two locations so how we first
authenticate the endpoints encrypt the
data validate that that transaction and
decrypt that data once it's made been
moved around so Google uses RSA 2048 bit
certificates to our front-end we use
perfect forward secrecy we were the
first major provider to use perfect
forward secrecy on our cloud and all
that's again by default you don't have
to configure out of that for your data
in transit the last point your data in
the data encryption in use is how you
can protect your data while it's being
used by by a server so this is it this
is a newer concept in the crypto
community and you can think of something
like home Orphic encryption which you
might have heard of as being a topic in
this space it's something that's much
newer it's not as practically applicable
yet Google does do research in this
space but it's way beyond the scope of
this talk so we're not going to talk
about that today so let's talk about how
you might be doing encryption right now
if you're if you're a company so if
you're a smaller company a startup if
you something on Prem or you might not
be encrypting your data at all or you
might be relying on your cloud provider
to protect your data so you're kind of
like the service a situation here
data it's there I don't encrypt it or
not I don't have the infrastructure to
manage that if you're a larger
enterprise company you probably have
some way of encrypting your data and
managing keys if you're in your own data
center you actually might not be
encrypting your data at rest in your own
data center but you might also be more
sophisticated and has like a custom
cryptographic library and a central key
management service or a kms that's what
you see in service B here so I have some
data in my application and that data's
encrypted with a key that's it's
centrally in a key management service if
you're a much more sophisticated
enterprise company you probably have a
more complex key hierarchy so we'll get
into what that means in a second but
you're not just using one key to protect
a they're using multiple layers of keys
and that's because when you start
encrypting things that really large
scale it becomes really hard to manage a
massive amount of keys you might also be
using something like a hardware security
module or an HSM to protect your data so
in applications see over here service C
you have seen data that's encrypted with
a key and that key that compared with
another key a key friction key that
could sit in that hardware security
module so it's a more complex key
hierarchy so what do we offer at Google
so you know you have a continuum of
options before if you're through things
on prime right now in terms of maturity
same the same idea at Google depending
on where you lie on this spectrum you're
gonna pick a different thing and it's
all about picking an option that's
specific for your company it's what's
picking an option that's specific for
your workload so the first option how we
do default Google encryption Google
encrypts customer content stored at rest
by default with no action required from
the customer using one or more
encryption mechanisms and I'll be
talking about this more in a second
we're the only cloud that does this you
don't have to go check a box to turn on
encryption it's just there this is no op
security for most of your workloads
that's probably good enough the second
one customer manager cookies in cloud
kms so as mentioned yesterday morning
that cloud kms is in general
availability I'm super excited what
cloud canvas lets you do is generate
encryption keys use them rotate them
destroy them there are a es 236
symmetric keys and you can use them
right now for for doing like application
layer encryption secret management
cetera if you have a requirement to
manage your own encryption keys that's
the option for you
the last option here is customers upon
encryption keys where Google does this a
bit differently than our competitors you
can provide us with some bits that we
use to protect your data I'll talk a bit
more what I mean by there in a second
but we don't actually write those bits
to memory sorry to disk we can only keep
them in memory so we're not recording
what you've given us anywhere at Google
we're the only cloud that has this exact
set up and that's pretty exciting so
it's already available for data objects
in Google Cloud storage and for discs
instances and image images and compute
engine and we have new partner
integrations that I'll be talking about
today if you have a requirement to
manage your keys on premise use multiple
parties to manage your keys or a
requirement to generate your own key
material and that's the option for you
so recapping you have an array of
options here you don't have any specific
requirements don't worry about it you
can like walk out right now your data is
encrypted that's great
you have a requirement to manage your
own keys cloud kms you increment to
generate your own keys sorry I keep your
keys on Prem or keep your keys in a
secondary provider then CSEC is the way
to go so I'll be donating to with each
of these offer so first default Google
encryption how does Google encrypt
everything at scale because it's massive
so if understand how we do that you have
to understand how we store data at
Google when an object is uploaded for
example to Google Cloud storage we chard
or chunk that object into smaller pieces
and then each of those chunks gets a
locally generated data encryption key or
a dek that key is generated on that
machine that writes that thing I'm
talking about storage layer encryption
here each chunk will have a unique data
encryption key even if it's part of the
same Google Cloud storage object as
another chunk even if it bonds to the
same customer is another chunk
even sitting on the same machine as
another chunk we have this super small
low level isolation cryptographically
isolation between how data and and how
date for how data is stored
access to those chunks is controlled
through access control lists a dapper
chunk level so the storage system
controls who can actually access those
chunks and those keys at that level
those chunks are distributed across
Google's infrastructure for latency
backup storage etc and we also actually
backup data encrypted we don't decrypt
it and re-encrypt it in the new backup
system we just take it we move it
somewhere else and it's backed up that
way so if someone were to try to walk
into you know Google and steal steel
Hardware steal something physical and
and take data they would first have to
know where all the chunks are that that
their object has been split into which
is a really non-trivial problem at
Google scale have access to all of those
chunks and have access to all the keys
that encrypt those chunks so where are
those keys stored well actually you can
think of them as being kind of stored as
like a header to that data chunker but
of course we're not going to write data
encryption keys in plaintext we're gonna
encrypt those data encryption keys so
encrypt them with another key called a
key encryption key this is a hierarchy
that I was mentioning earlier so we have
data encrypted by data encryption keys
and data encryption keys encrypted by
key encryption keys those key encryption
keys sit inside Google's internal key
management service or kms and kms was
built for that purpose so kms does not
allow keys to be exported rather that
dating cookies go to kms to be encrypted
and read cryptid and sent back that
allows us to have auditability over how
those key key option keys are used that
also allows us to have you know those
titles that we want again on how on how
you the usage of those keys those Kinki
encryption keys bye-bye services and
users is done canvas is highly scalable
and it has to be again to operate things
like google scale so it's extremely
incredibly low latency high availability
and globally available and what that
actually means in practice is that our
kms runs on tens of thousands of
production machines in Google data
centers globally so when when you
actually are pinging something and
getting a piece of data back if there is
an encryption process happening and it's
hitting a local instance of kms in order
to decrypt that data and get it back to
you
that's what allows us to have encryption
at scale at Google all right so you guys
are like okay I got no I'm skinning a
slide so first how does that work in
practice so you can think about this as
being three different actors here
there's a service that's using the data
there is a storage system that's storing
the encrypted data and there's a KMS
that's during the encryption keys the
key encryption keys so what happens in
practice is the service asks the storage
system for some object the sort just
some verifies that the service has the
right tax at that object figures out all
the chunks of data where that data is
figures out all the chunks in which that
data is stored
check those Ackles then it pulls the
data encryption keys that are sitting
with those chunks of data and passes
those data encryption keys encrypted to
the KMS the KMS then verifies that the
storage system again another ACK will
check that it has the right to access
those King corruption keys decrypt those
data encryption keys and memory sends
them back to the storage system and
those those people often ask me that
connection here between the storages in
the canvas that's an encrypted RPC so
you're not sending around plaintext keys
on our network and then from the storage
system back to the service the source
system decrypt the data and sends back
the plain text aid of the service in
most cases in some cases the service
decrypted directly again that's a
general example for something like SSDs
see it's actually locally managed SSD as
our locally managed key for the SSD of
the dek level but this in general is how
storage works in our systems sorry
encryption and storage work in our
systems so you're like ok we got data
data encryption keys qinger because it's
it's Turtles all the way down right kind
of so what happens next
this is the fun part so we said earlier
we have some blue data a yellow data
encryption key green key encryption key
and that key encryption key is stored
inside our kms all right but we're not
gonna write keys to disk right we said
that earlier it's not gonna happen
plaintext keys to disk
so when kms is not running in memory
where those keys stored well of course
they're stored encrypted on disk so
they're wrapped with a
kms master key and that kms master key
sits in another kms that we call route
kms and route kms is much smaller has
maybe a dozen keys that are really
critical to Google's infrastructure and
runs in special security machines in our
data centers route kms of course itself
protected with something called the
route kms master key so the route kms
master key is held in memory distributed
memory in a peer-to-peer infrastructure
that will call the route kms master key
distributor as have one part about
taking internal code names and try to
explain them externally I end up with
route kms master key distributor so the
route kms master key distributor is kept
in memory and basically what happens is
um a new jobs been seven says I'm the
route km about your key distributor gave
me the route kms master key and it has a
list of all the other hosts that are
running the route kms master key
distributor asset for the master key and
they they pass it back and forth and you
have another instance up and running I
think it's it's explain it in much
better detail in our security design
white paper but the reason this can work
in practice is that every job that's
been something Google has a unique
identity and so when we when something
spins up and asks for the route kms
master key distributor we know that
that's actually what it is it's not
faking and potentially another no rogue
piece of of code or something so what
that means in practice is that your data
is stored locally to wherever it is but
the data encryption keys the keys are
stored on prod machines in kms root
canvas is run on security machines in
our data centers and as long as at least
one instance of the root kms master key
distributor is running in memory
globally in theory we're fine right ok
now what if everything at Google goes
down what if every single Google Data
Center loses power simultaneously we
have nothing running a memory anymore of
working at Google people think about
problems like this what that means in
practice is that we've written that that
key to disk to security Hardware kept in
physical safes in at least two globally
just distributed Google locations that
less than 20 people have access to
and so with everything at Google were to
completely go down someone will go open
a safe
get our root campus master key put it
back into production as we turn back up
our data centers your dad will still be
there and I'll still be encrypted so
that's how that's kind of cool
so again quick summary that's many many
layers of the key hierarchy there but we
can we can do this in order to encrypt
your data asking Allah Google by default
the sexy line that you'd get to say is
Google help platform encrypts customer
content stored out rest without any
action required from the customer using
one or more encryption mechanisms
hashtag Google next 17 so there's a
white paper on our website that explains
us in detail all the same diagrams and
things everything I'm saying right now
is public and there are a few exceptions
around logs and that type of thing but
those are all explaining the way paper
we're not hiding anything here that's
what you get by default and once you
explain this to your seaso and they're
like no no I still need to manage my own
keys really great Google has this other
thing called cloud canvas called kms is
in now and general availability lets you
generate use rotate and destroy keys and
has a couple features that I want to
just highlight quickly one is um
automatic rotation what that means in
practice is that we can generate a new
crypto version for you that you can use
to encrypt data on an automatic basis so
you can say for example as a rule you
know every 60 days I want a new crypto
version created and we don't Rhian crypt
the old data but we you can therefore
limit the amount of any of data
encrypted with any single key the second
item here is 24 hour delay for key
destruction so I'm very terrified about
a customer potentially destroying an
encryption key without realizing that
encrypts data and therefore losing
access to that data for all intents and
purposes so we built in a purposeful 24
hour delay so that when you say destroy
key it goes into a kind of a temporary
suspended state for 24 hours you could
restore that key again to prevent error
insiders any kind of other risk that
could happen there I am in logging we're
integrated with cloud I am I have
predefined rules to allow for separation
of duties that I'll talk about a second
in logging
we're with Colorado logging
cloud logging has two kinds of access
two kinds of logs and min activity logs
which are owned by default which are
things like change I am permission
change key rotation policy etc and it
has data access logs which are not owned
by default that you can turn on that'll
say things like was this key used to
encrypt lastly kms is available via our
G cloud CLI client libraries in seven
languages including Go Java Python and
then through the the cloud console UI I
do often get a question so I'll just
point out really quickly it just like
our kms internally keith and cloud
cameras are not exportable so someone
will be like hey how come i can't see my
encryption key on the cloud console like
that's by design you can't see the
encryption key the only way for you to
integrate it interact with that
encryption keys to send data via an api
you'll get back encrypted or decrypted
data depending on the request that
you're using you're making let's talk
about a couple of concepts in called kms
so that we're on the same page object
hierarchy so clonk KMS as a concept of
crypto keys crypto keys are objects that
sit inside key things hearing searches
groups of crypto keys crypto keys are
like a named object that has a set of
crypto key versions the crypto key
versions are the actual cryptographic
material so when you're talking about a
new version we're talking about a new
set of cryptographic material that we're
going to use to to encrypt or decrypt
data the crypto key itself has nothing
and no particular material associated to
it key States crypto key versions can be
in multiple states that are listed here
enabled disabled scheduled for rotation
destroyed enabled crypto key versions
can be used to encrypt and decrypt data
disabled versions means that they can
not be used to encrypt and decrypt it so
far so good there's another important
concept to grok here which is that of a
primary key version a primary version is
a version that's used to encrypt your
data so now that we understand that we
were talking about key rotation earlier
generating a new sorry rotating a key
what we actually do there is generate a
new version and make that the primary
version so we're not talking about rain
crypting old data but we're limiting
anything else that you want to put that
key scheduled for destruction in
destroyed
what happens in practice when I was
talking about key destruction earlier is
that when you say destroy this key
we move it into the state scheduled for
destruction and then after 24 hours it
becomes destroyed if it's still in
scheduled for destruction you can
restore it get back to something like
enabled or disabled in terms of key
rotation I already explained what I
meant by have it having a new cryptokey
version created and making that primary
you can do that automatically so like I
said you know set a policy every 30 days
every 2 days whatever you want create a
new cryptokey version you can also do
that manually you can be an API call or
on the UI and lastly separation of duty
as I mentioned that we have some
predefined rules for I am what that
means in practice is is you might want
to have an organizational control that
says the people who use the encryption
keys are the same people who manage the
encryption keys so you set that up for
you already we have two roles and give
Alice the cloud canvas admin role and
Bob the kms crypto key encrypt or
decrypt her role and I mean Alice can
manage who has access to the keys and
rotations all of that and Bob can set up
a something to encrypt data using those
keys what happens in practice is that
Bob will probably be a service so you
probably want to give something like a
service account that rule we also have
encrypt only roles and decrypt only role
so that's something that you're looking
for
what makes cloud came a special things
that your SOA is gonna love scalability
global availability and latency
scalability you can have as many key
versions as you want so I had a customer
you know me they're like can I have a
thousand key versions I'm like of course
you do you want a million do you want
like ten million like just just hit us
the reason the reasoning behind this is
that we shouldn't have to limit how you
can encrypt data at scale just because
you can't have as many versions as you
want you should have as many versions as
you want this also enables a use case
which I'll call cryptographic isolation
you might have the desire for your data
that each of your customer's data is
encrypted with a different key every key
at every row in a table that corresponds
to a particular customers you can both
have separate key that's possible with
cloud kms
you can implement that that there's
nothing stopping you so go forth and
encrypt
the second one here at global
availability cloud kms is a regional
service what that means in practice is
that you pick a region in which to
create your your resources cryptokeys
and keyrings cryptokeys and keyrings
can't be moved or renamed or actually in
cloud KMS as case deleted you can
destroy all the cryptic crypto material
associated to them but you can actually
delete that resource and that's for
logging auditing historical purposes so
something like global availability so
you can create a key in like US East one
but you can still access it in Europe
there's nothing stopping you from using
that key globally so you don't have to
have a different keen each region and we
have optimized the keys in those regions
for latency but that's not that's not a
preventing you from using it elsewhere
the last one here latency cloud kms is
very fast and encrypt and decrypt
operations on the orders of tens of
milliseconds so you should be able to
use it in the serving path of your
application
you shouldn't not encrypt something
because you're worried about your
application starting up this should not
be a limit again again all the things
referees are gonna love and part of that
is also with our general availability
announcement we published an SLA
yesterday morning around availability
around uptime suites it on our website
and that comes as part of standard ok ms
okay I'll take up some water
so we've been talking about secret
management sorry
caption key is what I do yes please
please please help me with my notes
please we've been talking about
encryption at rest encryption so that
one of the first pieces for cloud
cameras might be encryption at scale
bulk data encryption so you might want
to implement something like a multiple
key hierarchy like I just described that
Google does to encrypt your data that
lets you have encryption at scale a
second use case is around secret
management so you might have some small
pieces of data that you want to keep
secret in your application so one such
example would be something like API keys
auth tokens some super special
credentials that you have something like
that and typically developers that I
talk to now are keeping those in a
variety of places but they include
things like directly in the code in the
metadata of a VM in a deployment manager
in a configuration file and in a budget
or in places and that's all fine and I
think we have multiple slides happening
ok cool
figure it out cool so you can store
secrets in variety places right now what
we're also going to be publishing today
on our yesterday our website is a set of
questions for you to think about secret
management and an option for how you
could omit that at GCP with what's
currently available so what I mean by
that is that there's a variety of
questions you might be having around
secret management probably optimize for
a few things around security and
functionality started security something
like authorization like who should
actually I have access to the secret how
do I manage access to that secret
version management how do I know that
all my applications have the same
version of the secret right now and that
they're all in sync encryption are my
secret encrypted arrest these types of
questions
I'm not gonna click anything the one
second
so what we're hosting our website today
is not a a be on at all you can think
there's probably a couple ways you can
improve on hand just recruiting secrets
in code the first one would be just
encrypt those things that are hard-coded
in code so that they're more protected
than if they were any any of your
developers can have access but some of
your developers have access a secondary
improvement could be something like
putting all of your secrets in a bucket
encrypting that bucket like a Google
Cloud Storage bucket and putting the
right I am of the write logging
permissions all that all around it
another option might be to use a third
party a secret management solution and I
think again this is another array of
options and complexity like how what are
you looking for out of this right if
you're just looking to limit a little
bit more access you're looking for
additional auditability we're looking
for more smart rotations like secret
rotation and more smart features like
secret rotation you might pick something
more complex so what we polish is is a
bit more explanation as to how we do it
with a cloud storage bucket cloud KMS I
am then called hollow logging it's not
the best solution it's not the best
solution for your environment
necessarily but it's one way you can
think about managing secrets in a
central way securely awesome thank you
the the last option that I talked about
earlier so we had cloud KMS so we had
default encryption we had cloud KMS and
we had a customer supplied encryption
keys and customer supplied encryption
keys so what happens here in practice is
that you provide us with a 256 bit
string we assume it's probably an aes
256 key that we combine that with a
random cryptographic naughts so that the
the randomness of that is sure to be at
least at some level and keep that in
memory and use that to encrypt your data
so we talked earlier about data
encryption keys and key encryption keys
what this means in practice is for data
objects in GCSE images instances and VMs
and she see we can use what you've
provided us plus a cryptographic
announced as the key encryption key
the more complex thing here is that you
might not have a really easy way of
managing those keys locally because we
need you to pass us that key as part of
an API call since we don't store that
can on disk only in memory and only for
the amount of time required for that for
that transaction every time that you
would need to access that object or
write that object or spin up that
instance or whatever you need to be
provide us that key in that API call
so what we're announcing today is a
couple of partner integrations to make
that significantly easier for you so if
you're looking to use customers and my
encryption keys you basically need to
have a kms on premise we have a variety
of partners we're gonna help us do this
for for you for customers without
existing kms solutions you can you can
look to work with them so using
connexxus product key Nexus Enterprise
on-prem and Connexus cloud you can
provision a cloud for a key for both a
GCE via G cloud or for G CSV GS utility
using Tallis and shield HSM switch our
FIPS 140-2 level 3 compliant so that's a
requirement that you have around fips
fips compliance you can supply a key for
use with GCE using virtru you can supply
a virtual generated key for use with GCE
using ionics products ionic protect for
cloud storage you can supply a key for
use with GCS and using jamal those
products safe that key secure a product
again a key for GCS so key nexus right
now supporting GC a GCS telson for a
true GCE and ionic ami Gemalto GCS we're
putting spend that in the future so you
have even more options for how we can do
how you can do key management with our
partners we hope that you find these
much simpler than managing your keys on
Prem and again we'd love to hear any
feedback on that functionality so again
how does this work in practice for all
these options would be mass storage
object this worktops you can split into
chunks chunks are creating corruption
keys the de encryption keys are gifted
with key encryption keys and the key
your pinkie will come from a variety of
places depending what you're trying to
do right it'll come from default Google
encryption using our internal TMS right
now you can move in a similar model
using application layer encryption for
cloud KMS or you can use a customer
supplied encryption key where you
provide us with some bits either
directly or via partner
one of our five partners it will add a
cryptographic nonce and then you said in
our system so that's all I was actually
going to talk about it so I write really
fast if you go to this link there'll be
information on all the options that I've
talked about today additional
information on the white paper I
mentioned we have a couple of code labs
that you can do using cloud kms so
there's actually one if you go to the
first floor downstairs
I'll also be standing outside of the
security area if you have any questions
and then will be a blog post next week
announcing kind of the partners and some
new functionality for secret management
all that kind of stuff thank you
[Music]
you